bienvenue dans comment devenir un ninja
par lemoine ninja des ninjas cette somme
est clairement aujourd'hui nous sommes
sur des airs ninja vers les jo ça
consiste à quoi ça consistait celui des
objets voilà c'est un peu nul donc je
propose que on se retrouve demain à plus
excellents non je suis pas jusqu'au bout
j'ai pas vu nous trop comme des
milliards du tube l'ont fait avant moi
je n'atteindrai pas ce stade donc il ya
des objets qui arrivent comme ceux kunai
le but c'est de ne pas bouger les pieds
au sol qu'on soit toujours sur la même
base et d'esquiver les coups nay
voilà ce qui relevait là est assez
facile ou que les ennemis ont besoin de
consulter optic 2000 tu vois un ninja y
consentent pas que sur sa vue clément il
se concentre sur tous ses sens s'ils se
concentrait pas sûr j'ai eu de la chance
si ce concentrer pas sur tous ses sens
il ne pouvait pas faire ça plus tard ah
ça commence à devenir intéressant dont
je ne vais pas vous mentir on était
calmes et la mise au real et demi
commence à être un petit peu vénéra je
peux parler munitions limite
effectivement bon nîmes pau trouver
larmes sont en révision
à l'inversé technique 1 1 grosse
technique un voile assez technique que
j'ai développée en une minute un bon là
on est nouvelle 4 lui reste à jamais les
ennemis visé aussi mal franchement au
attention là bas ils soient gardés à
droite un homme je vais prix bullshit
holla holla holla ce concept à bouger
beaucoup là oh là là j'aurais dû me
tirer le loup maire clément aura alors
joué face à un problème que bruno nahon
j'en suis sûr la démangeaison à cause de
ce tissu de merde pas du tout fait pour
coller à la peau vague 5 sur 10 clément
ouais
la sicile le montage a été bien fait on
aura vraiment l'absolution ninja travail
qu'est ce que je suis clément qu'est-ce
que je suis athée surfer lignol pardon
impo la paralysie avis au salon
franchement j'ai presque envie de passer
en phase de yoga je suis en train de
purifier monts et lacs c'est un lieu
sans pollution d'envoyer des bons
qu'est-ce qui se passe attendre à tout
regarde comme on voit la sérénité coupé
par les bombes des banques de cognac
d'accord on part vraiment là-dessus on
emploie vraiment les moyens pareils elle
est impliquée avec lé dakor faut que
j'estime et cognac qui part de la bombe
elle c'est chouette karting wave sept
sur dix alors là ça a mêlé kunai comme
ça les bombes et la totale c'est ça ok
c'est ce qu'il veut et où la bombe et la
sauge est-il tellement voilà c'est grâce
à mes deux doigts ça attention estivale
à matrix tu es prêt ou pas
dieu est fort c'est lucas et sculptures
à pied un petit élan s'il vous plaît
j'aime la méditer niveau 8 sur 10 et
ouais parce que j'ai mis un peu de
ménage au bout de mon stick ce matin et
merde
game over nord non mais cela placements
produits ménagers monde fait ça sans
déconner on peut plus garder samir 2016
parce que je propose c'est l'arcade mode
mode arcade on a cinq vies et là je
pense qu'on va se faire enchaîner deux
partout
ok le premier quart se connaît il vise
bien déjà c'est-à-dire le deuxième aussi
c'est à dire à lévis tous bien 100% de
précisions donc la bombe aussi non à la
bombe non pas des bons mâles voit pas
c'est drôle à je sers à quelque chose
j'ai l'impression de vraiment être le
maître de ceux de jouer de montrer à mon
disciple comment esquiver ses combats il
attrape et matérielles wahou fois mais
tu seigneur fasse comme on l avait bien
l abbé y est
g.skill un bol de ramen osta croyable je
viens vivre une expérience
exceptionnelle est clément je suis pas
fait l'amour braqué d'excellence été
bonne en fait j'ai pris à ramener ça à
tout mais au ralenti de brecht
actuellement pas les coûts que tu vois
pas où est un mec c'est chaud et la
pointe à la croix rouge à papeete à la
lok pas là dedans c'est là que j'ai eu
mal à laloubère au repos infinie
réapparition ça va mieux j'ai mis au
point une salle ou en fait une année
dans cette salle c'est une seconde ici
et j'ai pas coupé dbz ces parties là je
veux pas tu me thomas je vais tout et ce
qui les attend qu'est ce qui se passe
actuellement on connaît pas l'utilité
clip fly ses jambes est-ce qu'on va pas
la petite technique grenouille à merde
du ping pong la carte fait son
apparition
bon bon bon bon bon bon bon mec mais
c'est impossible d fois esquivé esquiver
les skis vencelas lombaire casser ça
c'est gratuit c'est quoi ça ah [ __ ]
mais là y'a pas le non non non d'accord
ça envoie des fusées sont pas sur un 14
juillet ah [ __ ] elle mais je me suis
fait enchaîner puisque au ping pong
devant sa possible pour me rendre plus
vraiment pas au traumatisme dans ses
yeux quand j'étais un castelet lui la
bulle sur mathis je peux dire qu'il l'a
vu ni pour le repos éternel
techni que j'ai mise au point comme
monfils m'emmerder pour jouer aux jeux
vidéo auxquels matin sur un jeu très peu
connue fruit ninja vert lol on va partir
sur un arcade là je vais te montrer une
technique très simple tu prends les
pieds comme ça et tu vois la go back
premier move que je fais je pète à une
bombe go robot low ce mec si je réussi à
damer c'est génial allez bon par contre
c'est super chaud est ce qu'il espère
que ça va ce mois budget pas de mythos
il y avait une banane bleue au stade y
avait une banane bleue non plus avec
deux je fais ça qu'à un sabre voilà je
suis pas du tout envie dex universe le
moins 1000 ex en business hormis un bide
en bide j'ai fait toutes et tous à ce bn
bon j'aimerais bien faire un ange est
parfaite c'est genre quand je dégaine je
dégageais mélanger non nul et si je mets
juste des petits coups ça marche pas
mieux c'est comme un cuisinier c'est
qu'un coupe une carotte comme ça toi
t'es jamais réussi à faire pareil pour
la presse par l'auteur de carottes crois
que c'est ping-pong montre matinée à toi
je vous tire juste délicatement la peau
je fais mon score mais je sais qu'on va
faire mieux vraiment c'est en mode
etxebeste et schématique
il fait comme ça hop hop des petits
coups comme ça très fin très rapide hop
hop hop hop hop hop ça marche trop bien
mais par contre si tu tapes avec le taux
de la lame ça renvoie le fruit un sale
coup possible théorie de merde est
stupéfait
sans descendre à fait calées classement
mondial c'est un sketch à temps il vient
de quelle dose aux mecs mecque le
deuxième mondial il a fait 560 le
premier l'a fait 4300 mais c'est un dojo
privée je crois que ça va coûter cher à
la nsa c'est la dernière qu'on fait
concentration
oui c'est bien ce que vous pensez c'est
parti
je sais que c'est pas viril mais je te
jure c'est pour une bonne cause les
normes dont joe de mes rêves
alors elle doit a battu le record est
bien un mec c'est con mais on a fait on
a fait 1050
on a battu notre record emilia 2017
qu'on voudrait faire des inscriptions
apb n'hésitez pas à vous inscrire pour
monde aujourd'hui accueillir les bras
ouverts
ma part qu'on voudra pas de salaire pas
de futur en rien nippon vêtements de
civils à aller mieux tout de suite bon
la ceinture quand même 10 po mais ça
valait cd ne laissez pas aller mais ça
vous a plu le tarif en est un jeu de
ping pong l'an dernier déjà mais
jusqu'où allons-nous allez allez a
besoin de moi j'aime bien regarder
portez vous bien déjà tout le monde